what up boo Singh what up do I got a
debate for y'all Raising Cane's a
chick-fil-a raising behind gang gang go
Tigers
dang bro damn duck raising Cain duh what
raising Cain duh takes over damn chicken
fillet raising Shane but you tell me you
got a shoe you told my god no comparison
you tell me you make it through the
Atlanta Airport without hitting the
chick-fil-a showing up at the counter
seeing a beautiful [ __ ] girls that
work at the counter I admit it they got
the best-looking women that work at the
counter you know when I start eating
chicken fillet huh when I came home from
prison flying in airports yeah oh yeah
you fought Delta do you yeah so I I was
raised on raise its no other chicken
finger that was the other first other
chicken I never ate his actions yeah I
said your Lena he did I still ain't any
dish in that land I looked at it I say
no it took my dystiny raising Cain I
looked at it I say hey I know because I
was raised on raising Cain like the
first ones and Louisa like I was raised
up yeah but dude chick-fil-a man you get
that little chicken sandwich you open
that [ __ ] up it's in that foil bruh
that thing looking at you like a little
newborn baby got that pickle on it I
hated befo bar I just know like I'm so -
pickles alright I got them soggy as
pickles ice cream pretty good okay
[ __ ] nuggets too small
one of those nuggets is three McDonald's
nuggets not coming off fire chicken
flares up now I like chicken fillet but
they ain't messing with no raising Cain
and there you go man I think you got it
I think you got your hands sermon
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one